il n'y a pas de première dame en france
non ça n'existe pas en droit n'existe
pas constitutionnellement ça n'existe
pas et je trouve assez inquiétant que
l'enfant de la personne qui a épousé
notre prise on attendait parce que là je
vais remettre tous en place la filière
déjà déjà qu'on donne de l'importance à
à brigitte macro cette dame de france
culture lui donner pour cet été et elle
le sultan et vous pensez qu'il faut lui
donner aucune importance je pense que le
fait qu'on regarde par le trou de la
serrure ce qui se passe dans la chambre
à coucher à l'elysée est la marque de la
monarchie présidentielle
c'était à l'époque des rois et des
reines quand il n'y avait pas de
démocratie
voilà il fallait il y avait la cour et
ont essayé de savoir avec qui couchent
et le le monarque était bon mais là je
suis désolé c'est encore là mais c'est à
militante
un feu de la france a subi ce qu'ils
nous bassinent avec la monarchie qu'on
aille voir c'est quoi la bande en archi
avant de parler je suis désolé françois
hollande s'est intéressée à ses
habitants mais ne lui lise mesila
évidemment ridicule je vous ridiculise
de dire mise
on s'intéresse à spécialiser ridicule de
dire qu'on s'intéresse spécialement à la
vie sentimentale des mâles mâcon s'est
toujours intéressé les miens les vins
sentiments tels des président nicolas
sarkozy lors cette région n'était pas
vérifiée gillain savent pas qu'elles
raquel effet le petit niçois hollande et
son scooter excusez moi bien sûr les
infidélités de françois mitterrand la
touche ça toujours bien aimé connaître
in ça n'a rien à voir avec la monarchie
dont car il faut arrêter avec elle juste
une escale à calais président si tu
permets suis pas d'accord je pense et
infantilisant jojo food avec kikuchi non
merkel si tu peux nous
si tu permets de conscience qu'ils ont
surtout qu'à l'adopter avec tous les
gens l'utilisent quelque chose d'un bon
c'est ce témoignage
ces témoignages à charge ans et une
jeune femme il est extrêmement fort et
plutôt que de l'analyser comme tu me
disais tu devrais tu devrais à mon avis
pensé voilà une femme une jeune femme
dont la mère est attaquée qui prend la
parole publiquement qui prend des
risques en prenant la parole
publiquement à fabriquer mais c'est pas
du pathos et comme ça si ta maman et
c'est amer été attaqué sa journée